“In the beginning there was nothing, which
exploded”
That’s how the great Terry Pratchett described
the beginning of the universe; the legendary
big bang.
The majority of modern physics comes from
the understanding that everything started
out as one tiny tiny point that blew up, expanded
and created all of the wonderful things around
you like galaxies, stars, planets and bacon
sandwiches.
As a planet, we’re pretty set on this concept
but that’s not to say it’s the only possibility
that’s been suggested.
Obviously you have the many religious creation
stories but even within the scientific community,
a few other options have been suggested.
So if you’ve ever wondered whether our universe
is actually all a cat’s dream, a marble
in the hand of a giant alien or a simulation
that has some worrying coding errors, well
then here are some alternative and entirely
possible theories to the big bang.
Our first idea was born out of string theory
and popularised by Steinhardt and Turok, who
sound like a German techno duo.
String theory is basically an attempt to connect
the ideas of general relativity with the bizarre
and confusing world of quantum mechanics.
The idea is that there are many more dimensions
than the ones we can observe and that something
that might look like a point from our perspective,
is actually joint a part of a long string,
like you are looking at a bit of spaghetti
dead on and mistaking it for a tiny speck.
Steinhardt and Turok proposed an idea called
the Incredible Bulk.
It’s not been entirely rejected by the physics
community, but possible because they are afraid
of making the incredible bulk angry, you wouldn’t
like it when it’s angry.
It suggests that rather than there being one
big bang, our observable universe is like
a sheet of paper drifting in a multi-dimensional
soup.
Theorists call these sheets branes, short
for membrane.
Occasionally our brane collides with another
brane and there is a big release of energy.
There is an endless cycle of collisions and
expanding branes.
Mmm brane soup.
Sean Carrol has been obsessed with time since
he was young, probably as a way to explain
why he was always late for dinner.
His trouble with the big bang was not that
it came at the beginning of time but that
time itself has a beginning and end; why does
time only move in one direction?
Well what if there were multiple universes
and in some of them, time runs backwards?
In the Multiverse theory, a universe can spring
up from the random fluctuations in dark energy,
which appears throughout what we think of
as empty space.
Dark energy is like glitter, it gets bloody
everywhere.
Sometimes the universes wouldn’t really
get going and they’d collapse into a black
hole.
But occasionally one takes off and expands
rapidly.
It keeps expanding forever and eventually
becomes so thinned out that it is now the
empty space where another universe can form.
One of the confusing things about the universe
is that it looks basically the same in all
directions, no matter where you’re looking
from.
Since we know the universe is expanding, we
tend to think of it as a balloon but for most
of us, this give the idea of a centre and
an edge, which is not really the case.
Fred Hoyle tried to explain this similarity
of all parts of the universe with an idea
called Steady State.
If you want to keep the density of stuff the
same in an expanding space, surely you need
to keep adding things.
It’s like a house party, if people keep
arriving, you’re going to need to keep adding
booze, otherwise everyone will either start
getting bored or possibly drinking all your
perfume and cleaning products and that won’t
end well.
In order to keep the density up, matter would
need to be spontaneously created.
And before you start picturing random bubbles
of hydrogen appearing all around you, the
amount suggested was about one atom a year
within each cubic kilometre, so no need to
squeeze up just yet.
Speaking of running out of space, in Christoff
Wetterich’s theory, we are all heading towards
a big game of galactic sardines, since rather
than expanding, the walls are actually closing
in.
He called it the cold bang.
One of the big observable factors for why
we believe the universe is expanding is the
Doppler Effect, or red shift.
We noticed that very distant galaxies seemed
to be redder than closer ones, and this was
true whichever way we looked.
So unless we were surrounded by a gigantic
red light district, there must be some reason
for this.
And there is.
If an object is giving out a wave, like light
or sound, then its movement affects how you,
the observer receives that wave.
If it’s moving towards you, then the waves
are pushed together at a higher frequency.
If the object is moving away, then they are
stretched out.
You can hear this effect with a police siren,
the pattern repeats quicker as the siren comes
near, and then seems to slow down as it moves
off into the distance, unless you’re being
arrested, in which case you’ll only get
the first part.
So, if the universe is expanding, then light
from distant objects is being stretched since
they are moving away, so it has a longer wavelength,
making it redder.
Wetterich countered this by saying that as
the universe closes in, the light would be
affected by the greater mass of the universe.
The benefit of his theory is that ait voids
the need for everything starting from a singularity.
The problem with it is that there is going
to be much less space on the beach in a few
trillion years.
Another factor of existence that is difficult
to explain is why everywhere is a relatively
even temperature.
Sure, it may not feel like that on earth where
you can get brain freeze from ice cream before
burning your mouth on apple pie.
But on a general level, like if you cut the
universe up into cubic light years, they are
all roughly the same temperature.
The reason this is strange is that 14 billion
years may seem like a long time for us but
on a cosmic scale, the universe is still a
toddler, wetting the bed and drawing all over
the walls in crayon.
The big bang was astonishingly hot so you’d
expect there to be more hot pockets, and I’m
not talking about that snack that sort of
resembles food.
Some theorist have wondered if maybe there
is some unknown energy that caused an expansion
faster than the speed of light, which would
explain how the temperature evened out so
quickly.
Niayesh Afshordi and his team came up with
the idea that perhaps our 3D universe was
not only in a 4D bulk universe but one that
created 4D stars.
And if you have 4D stars, these can collapse
into 4D black holes so perhaps we are like
sheet of paper, wrapped around the event horizon
of one of these black holes, sucking up the
enormous energy that would be surrounding
us.
Thanks to the work of great minds all over
the world, we are learning more and more about
what is out there and how it began; from the
quantum madness of the Large Hadron Collider
to the gravitational waves of dancing black
holes found by the advanced LIGO project.
But perhaps the true origins of the universe
are something we will never be able to prove
and maybe we don’t really want to know.
I mean, how would you feel if you knew that
we were just a tiny, insignificant planet,
in one of many tiny insignificant universes?
Or if the big bang was just the sneeze of
some 8 dimensional cat… actually I’m pretty
fine with that last one.